I don't know if you can hear me but I
made it across it's really bad here
Verlaine I think I think there's
something here
I mean isolation is that is the kind of
the alien game that we've always wanted
to play I think games based on the
franchise in the past have kind of
looked more towards the aliens
experience and that's totally cool you
know they're kind of the few versus the
many and the kind of the Horde of the
aliens but for us we felt that there was
a you know really incredible experience
to be had encountering just one one
eighty and kind of going back to the
roots of the series where we're you know
Ridley Scott's original alien is is huge
and terrifying and really significant
and you know just one alien wipes out
and in almost an entire crew that
obviously you have the alien which is
this kind of ever-present obstacle or
potential obstacle but it's very much
about how the player manages to fight
survive and and and and the choices they
make which I think makes it unique I
mean the best for the station itself is
you know it's a remote deep space space
station which is kind of broken and you
know that that in itself provides a a
puzzle you know it's a physically
dangerous place and so actually just
navigating through the world is it's
kind of like a puzzle in itself at the
same time there's a small inhabitants on
the station and they're in the same
situation to the to the player in that
they're desperate to survive and you
know in a new feature we're showing
today is is the seeks incorporation so
they're the company that run the space
station they have their own type of
synthetic they call working Jerry's
which seeks to no honors advances waning
yutani and so they're they're kind of
Android technology isn't as a barson and
so you have these kind of interesting
characters who are very much these
biomechanical entities who aren't
pretending to be humans how they react
to the situation means that the player
has to kind of react in kind of in real
time moment to moment
of what they need to do to in order to
survive so it's I guess anyway its they
keep the pressure on the player you
think you know we always wanted to make
the player feel underpowered and very
much underprepared you know you might
have an understanding of what you're
trying to achieve
ultimately but you know even turning a
corner is kind of unpredictable and you
know there's potentially something
you're gonna have to immediately deal
with so I think it's I think in
isolation is a really rich immersive
experience whether you you're very
familiar with the with the this universe
or not you know I think Ridley Scott's
original alien is is is totally you know
an amazing experience I mean I think I
was the starting point for us is you
know what would it be like to encounter
that creature and whether you're someone
watching the movie for the first time
back in the in the 70s or whether you're
playing alien isolation say I think
people still get that first response
that they had back then alien isolation
is coming out on Xbox one Xbox 360
Playstation 4 Playstation 3 and PC from
October 7th 2014
you